[Music]
and don't try this at home news dog try
a [ __ ] submitted by kumbaya my lord
that you know that sounds the same as
like Michael row the boat ashore it's
like the same uh what is it not
melody these are gonna start bleeding
from ugliness cuz you're Satan is it a
church look yeah yes that's why the
blood would here here are some of the
world's most ridiculous diets let me
know which ones I've done right I prize
say one of them is tapeworm was that I
thought that should work stupid my dad's
favorite diet that he says works the
best used to eat anything at all and
then at night he eats one of those
microwavable pizzas
wow what a disciplined man I wonder if
there was the all onion diet that was my
uncle I was like you want a diet he's
like yep I got a guy he said all onion
what do you mean all onion just the
wrong he doesn't even cook it no this
fool would like grade it and he would
drink onion juice you [ __ ] I'm like oh I
drink that she does a kid so when I was
a kid my mom used to cut up our onion
ginger garlic ah and then blend it and
then make me drink the whole thing in a
burn [ __ ] kid and then I
couldn't leave the house until I drink a
cup of that every single morning and I
would yak but it would take me like 30
minutes to drink a inch it's not good
for you dude what the [ __ ] that's just
gonna burn your insides are you alive
yeah residual all terminated yeah she's
all like you know what Windex is really
good for the window it keeps it clean
let me give my son a shot at that every
[ __ ] morning I better cut screen yeah
I knew a couple that it was a full raw
diet as in like for lunch they have
strips of chicken breast roll I just eat
right you can get like same but then
they were like he's Swedish like
bodybuilders and I'm like what the [ __ ]
I don't
there's everything wrong eggs everything
they never cook anything [ __ ] that [ __ ]
dude cook stuff tastes delicious does
I'm saying I won't need any of that
Chinese [ __ ] if it wasn't [ __ ] cooked
in a [ __ ] walk they would feel like
beef and some sort of whatever the [ __ ]
into a Tupperware let it ferment and
then eat that too I tried this one
French dish it was like raw beef oh
you're talking about the chop it up yeah
what is it tartare carpaccio is sliced
that's Italian I think it's seared on
the outside of this rod it's like having
a really rare steak so the first diet
that we're gonna talk about it's called
the Sleeping Beauty diet I sleep so much
you don't eat exactly I was like getting
kissed a lot when I was depressed I
slept all the time I didn't eat I lost
like 20 pounds I look great sad up here
but people down here that is the saddest
thing I ever heard in my life let's move
on before I kill myself I can't even
sleep if I'm hungry that's what saying
me too I've been woken up before by my
hunger pains all the time probably for
no reason and this has been like a
popular trend throughout the years bill
gets like value or xanax or something
them knock them out and they'll just
sleep for 20 hours and so the idea is if
you're sleeping you're not eating well
if you're dead an idea who has that kind
of time exactly mimic in effect the rest
of your life and then they're saying
that by over sleeping you're gonna end
up becoming just depressed because
you're not gonna be involved with your
in your social life at all and then
because you're depressed you're gonna
end up emotionally eating you're just
gonna gain that weight back anyways and
your muscles gonna atrophy anyways
[ __ ] all that weight that you're
losing gets all muscle mass isn't it
yeah yeah exactly and you lose muscle
mass too and it's just like ending your
metabolism is gonna learn that okay so I
don't need to work as hard if I'm
sleeping for this much amount of time so
then you're just gonna end up gaining
weight anyways Oh
sleeping too much is as dangerous as
sleeping too little yeah both of it
causes low quality problems and early
death and I sleep the or you need to go
to last sigh a lot about sleep sleep
hygiene yeah cuz everybody has different
requirements for sleeping huh
this guy right here is a bear he's like
hibernating everyday home I mean at
least 10
no.9 get him right Knights still alive
if I sleep nine I feel great goes home
so tired I only slept eight hours it has
to be perfectly nine so if it's one hour
less its you feel I feel I feel it I
never I can't sleep asinine in an hour
and a half yeah
what the [ __ ] yeah I need nine hours
that's already sleeping in too much time
half my body naturally wakes up no
matter what the only way I sleep really
really well is if I have nothing to do
like nothing is on my mind like it's
yeah that's true cuz if you have [ __ ] to
do that there's that sleep anxiety where
you sleep but you can't sleep because
you have to wake up early tomorrow and
then you freakin sleep just a little bit
before the alarm you sleep three hours
you wake up and then the alarm goes off
like [ __ ] man I need 30 more minutes or
whatever okay it's happened where I
sleep and then I wake up and I'm like
okay I gotta get up I gotta leave and
then all of a sudden I find myself
sleeping again for like another three
hours and then I get up and I'm like
okay get the [ __ ] out like my body hurts
I can't do this anymore
and then I knock out again and I sleep
for another couple more hours and then I
wake up again and in my head is pounding
coz I've been sleeping too much and for
some [ __ ] reason I just can't get the
[ __ ] out of the bed that's crazy
to be like three times I'm I love it
where it's like I it's like I had like
this sleep attack or something wish I
could watch the surveillance cam footage
well make you wait God boy oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
you better suck on my bag
weird where I was like dude I need to go
see a doctor something this is not
normal like how do i you're just
wrestling with the blankets by yourself
you know it's weird and a bad one every
day I used to have a lot of insomnia and
sleep issues before I was on a normal
like physical activity routine so that
that could be a lot of people's like
reasons and not seeing the Sun yeah if
you don't have the Sun touching you it
explains a lot for me cuddling you if
you know if your body isn't like moving
a lot and and you're not getting that
circulations I feel like we have so much
[ __ ] energy that we're not using that
we can't sleep so when you're just
sitting for like I don't know for most
of the day and then you finally get to
bed you just have all this energy and
you're not mentally stimulated or
physically stimulated and you're just
like I could probably stay up until I'm
tired well it's the Sun well you're
moving on to the next crazy night
photosynthesis sunburn diet in Asia or
something right where they were staring
at the Sun oh yeah we talked about it
yeah there's that yeah these women in
Hong Kong
yeah they go and this once was a big
beach and they just stare at the Sun
they're dovish they claim that the Sun
is helping them lose weight you're not a
plant for this you know what's sad all
of these crazy diets usually come from
Asia and it's caused by people I don't
know why the Asian logic well they don't
even use logic but they just make up
things and it becomes a fact like who's
the [ __ ] that invents it in the first
place
like the all onion diet I bet you
anything your uncle got it from like
Korean TV or news or something like
paper see it's like the same thing you
eat shark fin you're gonna get a better
boners you like that yes stupid but said
that that's true and then because they
don't use logic in Asia no one questions
it no one says you know what that
doesn't sound right I need
have this scientifically proven they
just go well it should like that in like
other third-world countries to like
they're like oh that little boy over
there he eats with his left hand he's a
[ __ ] witch let me just kick him out
and I'm starved to death stupid yeah
they come up with stupid [ __ ] like there
but Chile you see her hair she got brown
hair that means she's crazy you know my
mom's tummy Oh God my god watch those
Chinese kung fu movies where people are
like walking on water and like flying
through the trees and stuff and I'll
talk about mom like is that real she
goes yeah if you practice kung-fu hard
enough that's how you get up there like
that's how you're able to fly and I'm
like can see if we do that yeah I've
seen him jump over a wall see [ __ ]
like okay so I will practice like a
[ __ ] and I'm just like mom I
don't think my feet are getting any
lighter like I don't I tried like
walking up that wall and we got like one
step and he's got that people think that
was hired but the thing is I don't think
she was one of those parents that are
lined to the kids to make them try
harder I think she believed she believed
it your mom's so cool dude she actually
believed it herself yeah I met a guy
when I was going in for insomniac um he
was a fire performer like he's the
craziest the best fire spinner I've ever
seen
better than us yeah well not as you you
were good yeah he's like this buff white
guy like ripped and then you know he was
really cool and then he was like yeah
I'm sure you know I'm moving I eat raw
foods only and moving towards weaning
off and then just absorbing the sunlight
for energy and I'm like alright well
you're [ __ ] crazy and out he thinks
he's up lat yeah while he was saying
know where his pupils like this dilated
huh
he might have been on acid but when did
he die still going strong I mean he's
gonna eat fire instead a ritual whenever
it's my birthday he's like sending
cosmic rays to eugenia and sending
positive you what I would do people like
that they're like to understand any
positive right that's funny because I'm
sending negative ones to you right now
every Thursday oh no he's so sweet dude
I'm sending bad energy right now like a
Dragon Ball character I want to see that
[ __ ]
yeah which then brings us to this the
third dragon with diets so recently in
the news there were reports of this
couple who claim to be three Varian oh
god the air [ __ ] diet yeah you heard
of this no Nicole starvation it just
sounds so dumb it sounds like they were
trying to make a scientific name but
configure anything else it to me the
dumbest sounding [ __ ] ever that I
literally just guessed what is the
stupidest thing ever and I guess they're
right breathe Barry I thought it was a
tribe in the game of Thrones
yes riparian Steele [ __ ] take their
kids away
okay so initially when this was reported
they were saying that this couple
claimed that they almost never eat that
they lost we only eat maybe three times
per week and that she was able to go
through two pregnancies with that like
they were just reporting this like crazy
and there was a lot of doctors saying
like this is an incredibly dangerous
thing to like promote like telling
people you just let people do that so
they can die
natural selection right yeah so they
their children away CPS they look like
the babies look like they eat a lot yeah
so then there was a follow-up on the
this couple and then that's when they
cleared the air saying like okay no it's
not this extreme extent that the media
was was making it out to be like yes we
do eat but the thing is that we don't
eat as often or the same amounts as
normal people like we just eat whenever
we feel like it if we don't feel like
eating that we're not gonna eat so
basically you're being a normal [ __ ]
human being everyone pretty much yeah
and then they're saying that they don't
impose their lifestyle on their kids
their kids eat three times three meals a
day like just normally and so they're
fine but they have these courses where
they charge people in order to teach
them how to increment the energy that
they receive through conscious breathing
techniques and other exercises what do
their meal preps look like just empty
Tupperware containers
[ __ ] air casserole is off the huh
I want to see this dude open up a
Tupperware do this either that time it's
like [ __ ] remember hook when they
prefer the term present Norrish meant or
consciousness
instead of breatharianism there's still
some stone just call it eating like a
normal person
yeah see what we do is dip from what
everybody else does
cuz we eat when we hungry we do eat does
not the same frequency or intensity as
the average person when we went through
our reserves in transition 20 words
about see big I I wanna think that they
were trying to do it but them they're
both hiding the fact they're eating
behind closed doors oh I'm pretty sure
if you put a camera on that [ __ ] she's
got a bag of Doritos yeah and they're
trying to be supportive of each other
they're hiding it from each other and I
think they're getting away with it how
come you smell like they my own they
might just eat right I mean but I can't
do that mm-hmm oh yeah what's it like
eating one meal a day that hunger
feeling like it's not that intense if it
goes away after a while it goes away
yeah
it literally feel like somebody's
beating the [ __ ] out of me yeah yeah it
emotionally affects me yeah I get
irritable I'm like [ __ ] man I can what's
the hunger feeling hits it just gets
more intense intent like yesterday I was
so [ __ ] hungry my uber driver came
and I just looked at him I just wanted
to [ __ ] choke his neck Wow goodness I
remember having that feeling when I was
a kid like if we ran out of whatever I
wanted and I'm like I don't want
anything else but I want that thing and
I'm like hungry and I get angry and I'm
like mom I'm hungry and then she'd be
like ah just calm down and then like I
guess [ __ ] little kids
like from that I don't know like I kind
of got used to the hunger feeling where
it doesn't bother me anymore
I'm weird I'm no hangry I think it's a
actual thing it's actually natural like
a survival time yeah could you think
about it if a cheetah is hungry and he
can channel that aggression to go hunt
and kill something and have food finally
that actually makes sense
yeah that's why I wanted to kill my uber
drivers like to eat them I don't get
hangry so hungry I get a I get out
what's a call hang oppression repression
that's exactly why I don't get angry
like when I'm like Muriel gets angry I
get lethargic like I get lethargic angry
I'm like I'm so [ __ ] pissed I have a
Russia [ __ ] energy that's like the
last remaining energy to like kill I
turn into like one of those like Greek
slaves and those like sword movies of
[ __ ] please if it's like 8 p.m. and I
haven't had a meal that entire day and
then that's what I'm or like earlier
than that then okay earlier than that
I'll be like the whole day right and
then that's when I'll get hangry into
the point where it keeps you like why
are you so like annoyed right now I'm
like we should have ate in 72 hours I
haven't eaten all day and it's 10 p.m.
yes you have every right to be angry
like stay up and play video games and I
play all the way until I fall asleep
wake up and eat one meal and rinse
repeat cannot do that absolutely if I if
I can't stay in one place I feel like my
body starts to ache I have to move I
have to do something you know I can't do
that
can't can I do it I could do the
opposite of you where I'm eating the
whole day and then I take one break and
then I keep eating the entire day
I'm not normal don't don't do what I do
hope you guys enjoyed that episode if
you guys have any juicy little guts of
details and you guys wanna submit it
well guess what you can cruise on over
to the description box below click on
the link submit the story and hopefully
we will pick it and talk about it for
more videos click right over here